I started up this podcast about a year
and a half ago you were one of the first
guests come on and it was so much fun
talking to you I thought this is great I
didn't think I even wanted to do one and
it was so much fun talking to you I said
let's just keep doing these and see what
happens yeah but really it's just been a
blast thank you for that you're welcome
and I know you needed the money so I
invested badly talk about that later
everyone has a podcast they all doing
podcast it's like it's like jury duty
now like some wait for somebody to show
up at my house like you got to have a
podcast here's what I found out with
podcast if you have a podcast and you
have someone on your show to talk to on
the podcast they say hey when we're done
with this can you do my podcast yeah and
it's just this and everyone's just
running from podcast to podcast no one's
growing corn any moral there's no food
left in America no it's all collapsing
in on itself exactly because we're going
backwards it's like I mean so basically
we're just doing radio now yeah I mean
that's all is talking radio people and
and we keep going back now I think
audible they're doing scripted shows on
audible so it's like it's the old school
radio show I just recorded one last we
have Andy often is recording a podcast
while we're doing yes yeah he's in the
corner muttering yeah it's called double
dipping but it is funny it does feel
like someone's gonna come up with I've
got this whole new thing we go on a live
stage and we act out the show it's like
a that's called vaudeville right right
I've got back from it was like
television radio right and go back and
as a black woman I don't want to keep
going back
okay come on you're an ally so make sure
you if tap-dancing becomes big I'm
getting the hell out a bad sign they
start
[Laughter]